pas combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de
papus ne faut trop de quoi monter bien
sûr faut trois mois dans le cloud
attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]
m
merci le baht monsieur bourgault
monsieur bongo
j'ai un bon cigare un merci matin 8 tu
penses à mon journal du soir
oui sa suite c'est une catastrophe la
boîte de poudre de riz évident
pourrais-tu demandé à ces chères petites
bottes maui le baht nous faudra une
boîte de poudre aguerris
le grand modèle une paire de te paye les
miennes sont complètement rouillé il n'a
pas de teneur de ce qui se passe
elles sont gentilles je me suis très
bien habitué aux torrents pas maso
services partagés je n'ai plus de sucre
trop tard et battre son parti dommage
j'ai un peu porté sur fatigue et moi
avec toutes ses courses et ma poudre le
bac ça fait plus de deux heures qu'elles
sont partis elles prennent vraiment du
bon temps sur le manche à turin
[Musique]
au fait où est ma poule où sont les
tenailles de pâte à clous alors malade
ou est à charge du mall il est arrivé un
accident menottes sont malades
les votes sont malades pas tacle ou
balade attaque loup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais bien fatiguée elle ne veut pas de
fidèles à notre pas le trou et mata
cloud qu'est ce qu'on va faire un bon
morceau de cuir un peu de fil une
aiguille et ta bosse à sauver paraissait
en plateforme les peuples ça me redonne
vraiment du mois d'août et bottes le
chercher a peut-être tabac occasion il
me faut du rouge à lèvres et du parfum
et aucune aux pommes de terre si je
pouvais avoir un marteau et quelques
clous et boîte se sont interposés non ça
ne va pas recommencer
allez les gars on démarre
je vous en quatre ans guy berthelot bac
ressort à 12 heures
adieu adieu le bac je vous rattrapera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en attendant le fameux qu'il faut chaud
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pata
plus jeunes ils ne voteront débat
portait bien sur vos droits au hasard
par contre attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]